هل هذه الحسابات الخارجية قانونية التي
قمت بتحليلها ،
نعم أعني أنها تعتمد على ذلك ،
أه هذه الشركات التي تقدم
شركات وهمية وما إلى ذلك
فهي تقيم في ولايات قضائية
حيث تلتزم بقوانين مثل
الجزر العذراء البريطانية أو قبرص أو
أماكن أخرى حول العالم و  أنت
محق في الإشارة إلى أنه لا يوجد
أي شيء غير قانوني بالضرورة حول هذا الموضوع
ولكنه يخلق الكثير من المشاكل لأنه
يؤدي إلى التهرب الضريبي أه هذه
الأنظمة الخارجية غالبًا ما يستغلها
المجرمون لإخفاء المكاسب غير المشروعة
للسياسيين الفاسدين
أه وعادل  وكما تضعه في الجزء العلوي
من العرض ،
فأنا أعني فقط الأثرياء جدًا
في
نقل الأموال وإخفاء الأموال بطرق
لا يستطيع البقية منا
القيام بها أو لا يميلون إلى القيام
بها ، كما ذكرت في  مقال
مشوق أن نلاحظه في أعقاب
أوراق بنما والإصلاحات
والتدقيق الذي أتى من أن هذه
الممارسات مستمرة أه من قبل بعض
الأشخاص الذين ذكرتهم وهم
من هؤلاء  الناس بالطبع هو
الزعيم الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ، يوجد هذا
العنوان
في مقالتك يقول المال السري
العقارات الفاخرة وشرح مونت كارلو الغموض
هذه النتائج ،
لذا
فهذه قصة رائعة للغاية
وأعتقد أن إحدى القصص الأكثر إثارة للاهتمام
تخرج من هذه المجموعة.  تتعلق
الوثائق
بامرأة من سانت
بطرسبرغ يُزعم أنها كانت على
علاقة سرية مع فلاديمير بوتين
في أوائل العقد الأول من القرن الحادي والعشرين في الواقع أنجبت
طفلاً من المحتمل أن يكون أبوه من قبل
فلاديمير بوتين ولم يكن لديه خلفية متواضعة للغاية.
في الأسرة لا يوجد
دليل معين على أي وسائل مالية لها ،
لكنها أصبحت ثرية بشكل مذهل
منذ أن بدأت هذه العلاقة
وما وجدناه في الوثائق كان
دليلًا
على شقة بملايين الدولارات
حصلت عليها في موناكو
أه على البحر الأبيض المتوسط فقط في غض
ن  تم إنشاء شركة شل حرفيًا
بعد شهر تقريبًا من
ولادة طفلها وتمكنا من تتبع ذلك
إلى أحد الأمور المالية  جمهورية مقدونيا في موناكو التي
عملت مع أشخاص آخرين من داخل بوتين ،
وهذه حالة تتعلق
بكيفية عمل النظام المالي الروسي
كيف يمكن لمن هم قريبون من الرئيس
بوتين
أن يجمعوا ثروة كبيرة
وكيف يشرعون في إخفائها من خلال
شركات
وهمية لمحاولة ضمان  أنه
لم يتم إخطار الجمهور بذلك مطلقًا
وما يقوله الكرملين عن
هذه التقارير التي
قدمناها للكرملين ، لقد قدمنا للكرملين إش
ارًا وافرًا قبل أكثر من أسبوع بأ
هذه القصص قادمة أه أرسلنا ال
ديد من رسائل البريد الإلكتروني للحصول على تعليق من ال
تحدث الرسمي باسم  الكرملين ولم
نحصل بعد على رد واحد أو
حتى اعتراف
بشخصية بارزة أخرى في مقالتك
هي عنوان رئيسي عن الملك عبد الله الثاني ملك
الأردن ، هذا ما يقوله بينما
تكافح بلاده ، يتفاخر الملك
الأردني عبد الله سرًا
يسير بنا من خلال ما وجدته
يوجد لدي هذا أحد
أهم النتائج في الدفن أه الملك عبد الله
حليف مهم
للولايات المتحدة  يحصل الأردن على مليارات
الدولارات من الولايات المتحدة والحكومات
الغربية الأخرى ، وبينما كان الأردن يجمع
هذه الأموال ، كان حاكمها الملك عبد الله
يشتري سرًا شققًا فاخرة فخمة
في الولايات المتحدة ، أخذتنا
الوثائق وسمح لنا
بتحديد ثلاثة مجمعات على جانب الجرف في
ماليبو
أه لذلك اشترى من خلال
شركات وهمية باستخدام شركات وهمية
لإخفاء هذه المعاملات لما يقرب من 70
مليون دولار على مدى ثلاث سنوات ،
وجدنا عقارات في
عقارات لندن في
جورجتاون وقسم جورج تاون في واشنطن العاصمة -
تفاخر طويل في
الإنفاق على العقارات الفخمة في وقت
تراجعت فيه بلاده واقتصادها
أه منحدرًا ، هناك
بطالة كبيرة في الأردن أه
ركدت الأجور هناك
إنها قصة رائعة
لأنها تعطينا نظرة مباشرة
على ما حدث  كان الملك يتعامل
مع أمواله
بينما كانت المملكة التي يحكمها
تناضل ونحن فقط  أريد أن أشير إلى أن مكتب المحاماة الذي
يمثل الملك عبد الله أخبر المنشور
في مقالتك أن أي إشارة ضمنية إلى أن
هناك شيئًا غير
لائق بشأن ملكية عبد الله للعقار من خلال
الشركات والولايات القضائية الخارجية تم
رفضه بشكل قاطع غريغ ميلر شكرًا
جزيلاً لك
ونريد أن نلاحظ مرة أخرى أن سي إن إن لم تفعل ذلك.
قامت بتحليلها الخاص للجوانب القانونية
هنا تقوم CNN بالتواصل مع الكرملين
وممثلي ملك
الأردن للتعليق
عليك